truth is sometimes stranger than fiction
but when it comes to the stars of The
History Channel hits swamp people truth
is also stranger than reality television
think you know everything there is to
know about these muck dwellers well
think again because we're about to
reveal what diehard fans don't even know
about swamp people Gator bait in May of
2017
former Swamp People star Roger a rivers
jr. was arrested and charged with 20
counts of well pretty much everything
from illegally selling alligator meat to
marijuana possession so if you ever
thought the cast of Swamp People must be
high to mess around with Gators like
that turns out you were right at least
when it comes to Roger rivers quickdraw
swamp justice apparently moves a lot
quicker than traditional courts which is
something the operators of a shrimp boat
found out the hard way after chase
Landry's shot at them according to the
Terrebonne Parish Sheriff's Office
slander is in Bayou Chene in September
of 2016 hunting alligators when he fired
at the passing boaters allegedly
shooting a hole into a plastic gas can
which was on top of the cabin of the
commercial shrimp boat upon his arrest
landry claimed he shot because the
victim refused to slow down and would
have sunk their boat at least he played
it safe by shooting a gas can what's the
worst that could have happened
[Music]
five feet high and rising just one month
before is alleged a vigilante attempt to
stop a speeding shrimp boat chase Landry
spent five days in and around Baton
Rouge rescuing dozens of people stranded
in high water during the Louisiana flood
of 2016
Landry told The Times Picayune seeing
everyone get together and forgetting
about what color we are or what this and
that one said that was thrown to the
wayside and what was important came out
if you see your brother or sister a
neighbor and a bind you'll help them
unless they're speeding in a shrimp boat
in that case you know she was the most
explosive thing possible money shot he
may sound like a character from the
waterboy but troy landry is no fool not
only does he operate a successful
crawfish harvesting business he also
rakes in the cash making roughly 230
public appearances a year thanks to his
fame as a reality TV star so what has he
done with all that money
turns out he's built a dream home in the
Bayou which is entirely made of cypress
and boasts both an outdoor kitchen and a
thousand square-foot living room who
would have guessed selling stickers
featuring the phrase mud Africa could
possibly land you in the lap of luxury
that shirts Troy Landry's signature
striped polo shirt has become as much of
a staple on swamp people as captioned
dialog in dead alligators but according
to Landry this shirt holds a secret
hidden in plain sight under everyone's
noses he posted on Facebook I know
everyone is wondering why I wear the
same shirt the answer is we all do mine
just stands out because of the stripes
it's for editing purposes we bought 10
of the same shirts just think if the
other cast members had worn more
interesting shirts they might have
become the star of the show
cruelty claims over the years Swamp
People has come under fire from animal
rights activists the protest site forced
changed out competition The History
Channel to cancel the show rioting Swamp
People does nothing to educate people
about history it only promotes killing
it is very immoral to air a show that
depicts people torturing and killing
animals the Louisiana Department of
Wildlife and Fisheries on the other hand
argues that the program of regulated
harvest is actually a conservation
effort according to the department's
website our sustained you
management program provides direct
economic benefit and incentive to
private landowners and alligator hunters
slash farmers who lease land to protect
the alligator and to protect maintain
and enhance the alligators wetland
habitats so far the History Channel
seems to be siding with swamp people and
not the Gators but who knows what
changes the future might bring
later Gator Swamp People has actually
affected the alligator meat industry
according to a Miami New Times
investigation of the lucrative black
market that deals in alligator meat and
skin shows like swamp people and Gator
boys have fueled a surge in prices his
alligator meat became a novelty in
restaurants throughout the south
from 2013 to 2015 the price doubled -
875 a pound on the wholesale market and
trappers couldn't catch enough
alligators to meet the demand
The Times also reported that alligator
skins sell for anywhere from twenty to
forty dollars per foot that's remarkable
not only because the TV show could have
such a real-world effect on a commodity
like that but also because it means
people are genuinely basing their diet
and wardrobe choices on something called
swamp people thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all the
school stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you